[Musique]
salut salut les terriens alors les
terriens de ce soir sont christine
boutin
un testing boutin vous êtes ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy
présidente du parti chrétien démocrate
vous êtes fait connaître avec le débat
sur le pacs et vous êtes revenue en
force sur le devant de la scène avec le
débat sur le mariage gay alors qu'est ce
qu'on dit que le style en bout on dit
merci lépi
[Applaudissements]
autre terrienne avec nous ce soir marina
foïs
vous êtes une ancienne membre des robins
des bois vous êtes devenu en quelques
années une comédienne extrêmement
appréciée et votre césar l'an dernier
pour police en témoigne vous êtes marina
un formidable espoir pour toutes les
filles qui n'ont pas de sens
[Applaudissements]
encore une autre terrienne avec nous ce
soir izia juin
alors il ya bonsoir à 22 jan vous avez
déjà remporté trois victoires un césar
logiquement pour cette émission ça
devrait être un 7 2 or robert wood a je
préfére à autre
un terrien avec nous ce soir michel
onfray
ouais
et s'il ne fait pas le signe de la croix
ne sortait pas match appelez votre
gousses d'ail et votre cul en argent
c'est pas d'antéchrist non plus
bon j'ai discuté avec lui sign and trade
en p3 après le zapping et gaspard proust
nous acquérons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir latifa ibenge athènes
maire de la première victime de mon âme
énumérant voilà l'émission s'appelle
salut les terriens et le groupe les
gréement de fortune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il ya un rebond soir trois
victoires de la musique un césar du
meilleur espoir féminin à 22 ans vous
mettre au foot ouais malanda prix nobel
de chimie et meilleur paille là mais bon
vous avez bien conscience izia qu'on va
pas vous donner une récompense à chaque
fois vous faites quelque chose non plus
et ben non non non je les tendances
quand même à dire que les récompenses ne
font pas tout et c'est vrai je le pense
sincèrement il trouve qu'on m'en donne
et que merci pour ça et que ça me touche
énormément mais je trace ma route malgré
tout alors dit la fille de jacques
higelin et d'aziza ex choriste et ex
danseuse si les fils de l'efi de smet
avoir du talent il va rester 0 place
pour les autres à cette fois c'est sa
mère
vous dites je suis bien tombé j'aurais
pu être la fille de patrick fiori
en fait je change souvent j'ai parfois
que je la vis de francis cabrel voix non
mais c'est vrai je suis la fille de
jacques higelin fille de et fier de
l'être ouais
bon jacques larivée jacques higelin a
tranché
comme de retard donc à ces temps déjà
des pieds sur scène avec votre père à 13
ans il vous offre une guitare une fan
d'alain vous faites votre premier
concert à calvi dans un festival qui
s'appelle festival du vent j'avais monté
un groupe pour l'occasion et voilà je
vais jouer quoi j'ai joué des chansons
qui sont déjà sur vous compreniez album
donc des titres qui étaient déjà là quoi
il vous a dit quoi votre père quand je
dis le césar
je me suis effondrée en larmes en
sortant de scène chez les maquilleuses
qui se sont tellement elle même mise à
pleurer j'étais venu pour moi alors j'ai
appelé mon père qui pleurait aussi
c'était une espèce de mise en abyme de
larmes et tout le monde chiale et
c'était super cool mais mon père mon
père il pleure tout le temps dès que dès
que j'ai su faire un truc qui est du
compte je pense qu'il était déjà au
maximum de sa fierté au moment où je
suis sorti du ventre de ma mère donc
partir de maintenant c'est que du bonus
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
massy infiniment je suis extrêmement ému
extrêmement touchée je vous remercie à
l'académie devoir voter pour moi je
remercie du fond de mon coeur patrick
mille
pour m'avoir permis de réaliser voilà
c'est un peu con mais mon rêve et je
remercie bien évidemment justine lévy
aussi et c'est robert dit merci voilà la
musique toujours et maintenant le cinéma
j'espère aussi beaucoup voilà j'avais
danser seul dans un coin mais non merci
alors y'a un truc incroyable c'est que
les années passent les générations se
succèdent mais les remerciements sont
toujours pareil bah oui non mais c'est
sa vraie dit pas de gros mots
mais ya rien yahia il ya eu un [ __ ]
plus en loucedé a quand même s il est
sorti malgré malgré lui que j'ai pas vu
le film parce que quand on m'a dit c'est
la fille de jacques higelin dans un film
inspiré par le livre de la fille de
bernard henri lévy j'en voyais ma fille
le voir en
mai mais le dvd sort le 3 avril et je
l'achèterai
ça s'est passé comment le dîner au
fouquet's après la cérémonie
normal enfin moi j'ai un élément de
comparaison que la musique donc je pars
c'est moi forcément je peux voilà c'est
quand même un peu plus fun mais c'était
très sympa aussi j'ai appelé mes parents
ils sont venus et m'ont fait un câlin
puisque j'avais besoin d'être avec les
gens qu'elle aime quand même tu santa
marina elle était très sympa c'est vous
piquer votre césar non non un nom oui
j'ai rien pu faire non mais c'est là une
des premières personnes que j'ai vu en
sortant de scène est avec ludivine et
j'étais vraiment adorable j'étais pas
nommé donc je pourrais être vraiment
vous donne un espoir c'est foutu
ces quatre joueurs vous l'avez des pays
non non j'ai meilleurs trucs dedans
quand on fait comme ça hein ah bon
meiway j'entends gling gling alors
j'essaie va notre micro alors marina
rebond soit vous avez déjà été nommé
trois fois
nassian
[Musique]
difficile quand même après la cérémonie
à chaque fois de dire à laurent weil
c'est déjà un plaisir d'être nominé
non sans le 10 à 20 oui parce
qu'apprendre n'est plus interdite vous
partez en cours avant ce qui était très
drôle c'est que vous aviez croire que le
v u l'an dernier je trouvais ça génial
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
je veux juste dire un petit truc voilà
on dit beaucoup c'est pas grave de ne
pas avoir le césar ce qui compte c'est
d'être nommé emma c'est pas vrai non
mais faut pas mentir aux jeunes c'est
horrible de pas l'avoir c'est atroce
hyper mignon tu arrives en limousine tu
repars en bus non en plus y'a un truc
c'est que c'est cruel parce que tu te
souviens pas de ce qu'ils ont pas 1
alors que bon après toujours pas si mal
que ça non mais c'est vrai par exemple
l'année dernière meilleure actrice vous
souvenez qui étaient nommés n'ont par
contre vous souvenez très bien qu'il a
eue bérénice bejo pardon bérénice béjo
non c'est moi qui l'ait
non c'est bérénice bejo dont six
artistes
mais non c'est du jardin dandy arte
non c'est bérénice bejo non l'année
dernière meilleure actrice marina foïs
dans polisse
embarrassant marina si j'étais pas vous
l'avez enregistré la cérémonie donc je
serai bien repasser les images
ok très bien que votre volonté soit
faite des images la meilleure actrice
2012 et le césar de la meilleure actrice
est attribué à bérénice bejo d'anciens
artistes
[Applaudissements]
j'étais à deux doigts de me faire douter
je tiens à préciser que c'est un texte
écrit par leurs rangs la fiq est
vachement drôle bravo laurent vraiment
c'est très droit vais tellement marre de
cette histoire de césar que vous avez
décidé de tourner dans boule et bill
tranquille je risquerais voilà une
comédie d'alexandre charlot et franck
magnier qui est sorti mercredi dans le
pitch est très simple c'est une famille
qui adopte un cocker qui est roux comme
le petit garçon d'air on regarde à quoi
ça ressemble
[Musique]
je vote voisins du dessous ah bon jour
on chantait
moi je fais une dépression et il ne faut
pas de bruit du tout du tout à travers
ben je vais voir ce que je peux faire
bon après midi on sait qui je suis
maintenant
tu vas jouer avec la sourdine pas grave
on
[Musique]
chez votre voisin du dessous oui je les
ai reconnus tu prends des médicaments à
cause de ma dépression si bien il faut
et sam a développé une sensibilité
auditive
très étonnante j'entends tout tout tout
tout temps qu'il vous faut pas de bruit
et tout du tout du tout du tout c'est
gentil
voté un peu de lecture rythmique
voix voulez dire en salles depuis
mercredi
il faut dire c'est un trio après tous
ces films français qui ne marche pas
celui-là a fait 200
4535 entré le premier jour le premier
jour un videur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est remarquable
c'est peut-être le film qui va relancer
la fréquentation des salles on compte
beaucoup sur le moment c'est être les
signes qui va arrêter la crise en
faire beaucoup des chances alors c'est
vrai que le chien avait une loge plus
grande que celle de franck dubosc bien
ouais c'était ouest et la star je me
demande s'il frank aurait pas dû jouer
le cabot finalement non il aurait joué
moins bien corps alors marine à tout va
bien les saleuses vous avez déclaré ya
pas longtemps que vous avez commencé à
vous accepté il ya quelques années
vous avez décidé de vous [ __ ] la paix
se disent ah ouais mais c'est pas mal
car j'ai arrêté de m'emmerder moi même
toute la journée je me foute la paix tu
sais pas si c'est moi où tous les gens
qui sont comme ça mais moi j'aurais
voulu être très grande très brune très
différents à autre chose nous a menés là
comme constitue une bouteille
voilà
et très catholique non mais non celle
avantage de vieillir voire moins de
temps sur je me consacrer trop de temps
c'est chiant 6 terrible ça ça vaut
bosser pour la ba oui oui oui et le dé
le travail aide à se détacher de sa
branche média tu te fous la bête
j'emmerde les autres
on voulait la paix oui j'ai l'impression
oui je pense qu'il faut effectivement
c'est une bonne leçon de sagesse et ben
voilà sur l'interview sur cette leçon
celle de michel onfray nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de christine
boutin
vialle l'un des méchants
alors que si mme boutin re bonsoir
vous avez dans votre combien de sièges
relooking cette année aucun non non j'ai
grossi j'ai maigri kouassi gervais gris
quand je parle de relooking c'est les
cheveux tatouages comment vous étiez
gothique comme un beau soleil vous aviez
raison l'or noir c'est vraiment bonne
mémoire banner ma caisse qui dit jésus
sur les ongles noirs c'est pareil ça lui
plaît à jésus ça je pense qu'il s'en
fout un peu avec ce qu'en font avant
d'accord mais vous pensez que c'est que
les gens n'aiment pas chez vous c'est
votre look alors vous changer tout le
temps de look mais ce que les gens
n'aiment pas que financer vos idées
ils sont en droit oui ils ont bien sûr
mais j'ai le droit d'élire les miennes
aussi bien que vous ayez énormément
changé ces derniers temps que les steen
je crois qu'on peut le dire ce soir ici
pendant les manifestations contre le
mariage gay vous avez rencontré frigide
barjot
ça a été le coup de foudre vous allez
vous marier c'est non c'est non
non je sais pas parce que écouter
honnêtement sur toutes ces
manifestations j'ai plutôt été très en
retrait ouais non j'étais pas chère eva
partie de la coordination
d'organisations même si sur le plan des
idées je soutient naturellement
totalement c'est cette démarche et je
suis très très frappé par la
mobilisation de ces français qu'on
n'attendait pas du tout le reste c'est
bizarre qu'on va être mariée tout le
monde a vraiment un moment où plus
personne se marient
mais alors s'il fut cet acharnement
contre le mariage gai de votre part et
de la part des gens qui pensent comme
vous c'est quand même dieu qui a créé
les homosexuels christian non non parce
que
la guerre la vraie question serait oui
mais aussi il m'a créé mois il a créé à
michel onfray jamais norme ias qu'il est
bon vous voyez qu'il aime il est très
gentil alors il a créé les homosexuels
c'est même pas un problème d'homosexuels
le mariage gay c'est pas du tout ça
c'est un faux nez l'histoire des
mariages homosexuels c'est à dire qu'on
veut construire une société sans
différence sexuelle et avoir la maîtrise
sur l'ensemble vous n'êtes pas fait
comme moi non mais bon ça bah oui mais
moi j'y tiens
moi je me demande si l'église s'acharne
pas contre le mariage gay parce qu'ils
ont peur que les prêtres se marient
entre eux
savaient les prêtres sont comme le tout
ce sont des hommes oui qu'ils sont
faillibles et il y en a peut-être est du
reste il me semble qu'il ya quelques
scandales au vatican qui vous attend
pendant par l'existence est
normal mais il faudrait quand même pas
que votre combat contre le mariage gai
laisse penser aux gens que vous refusez
le sax les styles côté j'aime le sexe
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que non d'ailleurs vous êtes
marié et vous êtes marié avec votre
cousin germain c'est légal ça ouais
c'est là-bas tabac illégal j'espère
pourquoi c'est pas les gars ce que pour
un mariage entre cousins germains ce qui
à mon avis est contre nature je vous dis
franchement il faut une dispense du pape
non mais c'est vrai je plaisante
mais alors que tu es sur le mariage
civil oui je n'ai pas besoin de demander
l'autorisation est président de la
république oui la france la république
française n'interdit à bien sûr en
aucune manière le mariage entre cousins
en ce qui concerne l'église catholique
il faut effectivement une dispense mais
et je pense qu'elle a été demandée mais
c'est vieux moi vous savez depuis
combien de temps je suis marié non ça
fait quarante six ans alors vous savez
vous plaisait toujours absolument et mon
mari l'ont fait toujours voilà votre
cousin buy ont annoncé mon mari dit à
vous et vous aurez votre cousin germain
ah non ah les voilà tous et c'est contre
nature c'est bien c'est pas contre moi
je n'ai jamais pu épouser ma cousine a
passé à ce que vous n'êtes pas tombé
amoureux de votre cousine allons tomber
amoureux de sa fille assez fréquentée
par
enfin six ans parce que d'abord c'est
entre cousins germains précédé frères
l'islam avec les abîmer c'est ce qu'ils
valent
c'est ce qui va arriver avec l'apéro
c'est cela bolide a dit ça commence
comme ça
j'avais vu ça sur vous qui disiez ça que
moi amusez vous auriez votre cousin
germain bah non je m'en fous
j'ai commencé avec pas mal je suis plus
moi c'est mon mois de mariage je vous
fais remarquer ça va devenir très
moderne comme tous les [ __ ] qui vont se
marier
heureusement qu'ils sont là pour faire
marcher production parce que sinon
mon mariage gai savoir qui se vend
environ
bon christine j'étais très heureuse
d'apprendre que vous aviez toujours le
sexe
je suis ravie
j'ai envers robin soir alors michel
vous êtes ici pour expliquer à christine
boutin que non dieu n'existe pas c'est
comme le père noël faut être courageuse
maintenant alors michel pour vous dieu
n'existe pas mais alors qui a créé le
cube beyond si
douce à ce critère une chose aussi
divine que le cul de beyoncé ça vient du
big bang c'est une espèce de bulle c'est
le big band café sachets lit par sa part
vous par faire vivre la vie de vang
en fait vous laisse vous le dire c'est
que si dieu n'existe pas tous les mecs
qui sont fait chier conçoit des églises
et des cathédrales et où ils ont perdu
leur temps en fait non parce que c'est
bien les cathédrales l'avant vous êtes
pour les captures la musique et la
culture donnée dans une culture judéo
chrétienne de gouaix depuis plus de
mille ans je n'existe pas à quoi ça sert
d'avoir fait tout ça oui mais les dieux
n'existe pas et depuis toujours des gens
ont besoin de dieu on n'a juste pas
envie de mourir et de dire après la mort
y a rien donc on invente des fictions
alors il ya une fiction évidemment sur
dieu mais ensuite une fiction sur jésus
un construction de jésus temps
pour moi vous pouvez pas nier alors vous
allez droit de dire tout mais sauf ça
j'estime à sanaa puisque j'avais jésus
qu'on adore n'a rien à voir avec le vrai
jésus meshes jésus c'est un déconneur
sais pas
c'était un juif qui foutent la merde
qu'est ce que t'es marie madeleine voici
cinq ans
vtb sembla que jeune majeur de la
semaine du tout je suis catholique moi
ce que j'aime c'est jésus c'est son côté
rebelle bon il existait michel peut pas
dire que c'est une fiction si c'est tout
de suite c'est ce qu'on a fait une
section mais non ça c'est quand même
fabriqué jésus il n'est dans un endroit
qui n'existe pas à l'époque
tapparel ça existe quand même des maroc
où jésus est censé naître cet endroit
n'existe pas ce personnage est fabriqué
à partir de l'ancien testament on a
annoncé un messi qui viendrait il n'est
pas venu on a juste dit il est venu il
s'appelait comme
c'est la tradition juive oui oui mais
reconnaît pas mais judéo christianisme
donc ça a été fabriqué comme ça avec
saint paul qui est juif à l'origine
caisse converti au christianisme a fait
partie des premiers à tuer les premiers
au nom du christianisme comme saint paul
massacre quand même saint-etienne et
contribue au premier des massacres se
convertit au christianisme et fabrique
le christian bale est une pratique secte
qu'une petit sac de rien d'une amap ou
des petites sexe qui existe mais il est
évident aujourd'hui dans une petite
salle qui vont un petit sac d'un média
en fait jésus jésus c'est une invention
mais si c'est comme monsieur propre la
mère denis mais s'il non mais tu irais
je vais être obligé de quitter plateau
non non non non mais parce que
ce n'est pas passé monsieur le vieux
vous le dire mais moi je suis catholique
donc je pourrais pas supporter etienne
plateau sablon reconnaissez qu'on peut
avoir des visions différentes de jz
n'ont aucun évangélisme inconnu jésus ça
a été mais qui pourra compter mais
j'avais m'étrangler la
considérant ces vous soyez aussi peu au
courant de l'histoire de votre religion
gr estac bat penser même si je me la
faire moi même non mais moi aussi non à
la fois non mais laissez moi l'histoire
la faune en lisant la christie n'en
attendait sérieusement vous qui savez
que dieu est contre le mariage gai
existe qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de
michel onfray
et il aime
cette odieuse voilà
ils sont 28 avril sort alors on continue
avec michel michel vous êtes un
philosophe athée et vous êtes l'un des
deux plus célèbre philosophe hédoniste
français le tse marc dorcel vous allez
je me doutais que
dans l'hédonisme ckoi tiens voilà le
christianisme naudy souffrait de votre
vivant et plus vous souffrir de votre
vivant pour vous plus vous jouirez après
votre mort sauf qu'il ya pas de vie
éternelle il n'y a pas de vie après la
mort à la mort y à rien un hédoniste
c'est quelqu'un qui dit ne loupez pas
votre existence il n'y en a qu'une et
tâcher de savoir humain mais le plaisir
est de donner du plaisir à autrui en
évitant votre des plaisirs et le
déplaisir d'autrui dakar j'ai fait coups
bas c'est parfait non mais je comprends
un truc c'est que c'est né en grèce
l'hédonisme quand on voit l'état du pays
on comprendre
des mecs qui ébranla
la grèce de platon
finalement votre truc c'est le pari de
pascal à l'envers le pari c'est un truc
que pascal invente pour essayer de
convertir les athées les libériens qui
sont des joueurs il essayait de cesser
d'utiliser leur technique moi je dis
faisons de l'histoire simplement on ne
fait pas d'histoire aujourd'hui quand on
fait de l'histoire mais sur sa de sur
sartre sur etc ou sur le parti
communiste ou sur du 50 on commence à
faire de l'histoire on découvre des
choses extraordinaires mais les gens
veulent des les gens qui préfèrent des
illusions qui leur font du bien à des
vérités qui leur font peur là vous
faites une transition formidable michel
parce que vous êtes hédoniste mais
bosseur vous publiez deux gros bouquins
chez grasset le volume 8 de votre contre
histoire de la philosophie les freudiens
et l'éthique et le volume 9 les
consciences réfractaires alors après
avoir déboulonné freud dans un bouquin
génial qui s'appelle le crépuscule d'une
idole paru en 2010 avec les freudiens
hérétiques vous présenter d'autres
psychanalyste que freud a tout fait pour
évincer parce qu'en fait frakes que ce
que j'apprends en nylon votre bouquin
c'est qu'en fait il ramener la
couverture à lui voulait pas qu'on parle
des autres freud a fait une espèce dopé
assure la psychanalyste dix ans les
petits caïds c'est moi en dehors de la
psychanalyse c'est pas des psychanalyses
et je montre simplement qu'il ya une
espèce de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
intellectuel collectif c'est-à-dire une
cinquantaine la plupart juifs de génie à
l'époque devienne un d'action de les
gens extraordinaires qui pense une
discipline nouvelle la psychologie et
qui propose un certain nombre de choses
et fraudes qui dit non ça c'est moi et
les autres n'existent pas plus vous
dites que freud en fait quand on le lit
comme il faut il a légitimé tous les
totalitarismes
du xxème siècle en fait une totalité
reste de droite ouais surtout je fais la
démonstration que de fait il ya chez ce
personnage là une théorie alors
primitive nous dit nous sommes des
animaux les animaux ça se dresse voilà
il n'ya qu'une personne susceptible de
dresser le dictateur il nous faut des
dictateurs à lundi fraude alors
l'impression que la définition de
l'hédonisme c'est la démolition non
questionne par le big bang alors l'autre
livre que vous publiez s'intitule les
consciences réfractaires en là vous y
célébrer les penseurs qui ont résisté à
toute forme de soumission politique ou
idéologique alors ya georges politzer
communistes qui refusent le pacte
germano soviétique
c'est à dire que pendant deux années les
communistes français encore labour est
ce qu'on n'a pas dit évidemment parce
qu'ils considéraient qu effectivement
les nazis et les communistes avaient des
ennemis en commun les juifs la
bourgeoisie le capitaine anglais général
de gaulle devrait donc pendant deux
années les communistes invite à
collaborer avec l'ennemi et
effectivement quand hitler entre en
union soviétique le pacte explose 1 à
partir de ce moment là le parti
communiste devient résistant mais pas
avant et lorsqu'on apprend en lisant
votre bouquin c'est qu'il y avait des
tracts du parti communiste qui
appelaient à ne pas résister aux nazis
et que guy môquet le fameux guy môquet
oui le pote de sarko guy môquet lui il a
distribué des tracs pro nazi selon guy
môquet il est en prison pour avoir
distribué des tracts défaitiste ouais
c'est à dire de collaboration avec
évidemment quand les nazis le prennent
comme otages et le fusil que c'est un
grand un grand personnage guy môquet à
ce moment là parce qu'il va droit à la
mort et il ya beaucoup d'élégance ce
jeune garçon mais il est en prison non
pas pour eux accrus de résistance pour
faits de collaboration de défaitisme
sinon c'est quoi ce faux qui a été
fabriqué après la guerre par le parti
communiste pour faire croire qu'ils sont
rentrés dans la résistance en 1940 à la
libération il faut laisser croire qu'on
a été résistant donc on invente plein de
légende et on fabrique un faux numéro de
l'humanité daté de l'époque où on aurait
pu être résistant disant voilà on
appelle à la résistance simplement cette
info il a été fabriqué extériorise c'est
énorme c'est eleven vous gagnez génial
parce qu'après vous atomisé le couple
sartre beauvoir on dit qu'ils ont
toujours été d'accord pour avoir lui des
maîtresses et elle des amants en fait il
l'imposé sa polygamie à sa femme ce qui
est vraiment pas bien
[Rires]
tout ça parce que tu sais pas si vous
savez qu'il sait jamais évadé du stalag
que ses trios de la rochelle écrivain
d'extrême droite qui l'a fait sortir
sa vie quand c'est bien tous écrit que
ce que sartre écrite dans une revue
collaboration comedia comédiens en 41
voilà on 443 comédiens revue contre la
bo le décret totor de l'année voilà que
le directeur de comédiens pistone simone
de beauvoir qui travaille à radio vichy
etc et voilà et last but not least
sartre n'a jamais dénoncé les camps de
concentration soviétique il s'est même
attaqué à david rousset qui lie le
pauvre les dénoncer voilà donc son
arrivée habillée pour l'hiver jean paul
ça alors dites moi si c'est pas
fatiguant de toujours dire des trucs
intelligents comme ça pourrait pas dire
une connerie dit un truc con non je suis
n'a pas existé par exemple
voilà on passe maintenant à l'actualité
de la semaine avec l'éditeur de blacko
et c'est le journaliste écrivain italien
alberto toscano que nous retrouverons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto
les cardinaux bientôt élire un nouveau
pape mais pour que le prochain pape soit
vraiment nouveau faudra qu'il soit
vraiment différent de ses prédécesseurs
alors pourquoi pas un pape africain
après tout n'est pas impossible puisque
le cardinal turkson un ghanéen de 64 ans
est le favori des bookmakers anglais sur
la photo un pape noir on pourrait
comparer à obama sa très moderne sauf
qu'en réalité doerksen n'est pas
franchement un progressiste en octobre
lors d'une réunion organisée par le
vatican il a projeté un film dénonçant
l'invasion démographique de l'europe par
les musulmans en plus il avait piqué le
clip sur internet et tous les chiffres
cités étaient complètement faux sinon
quand on l'interrogeait sur cnn à propos
de la pédophilie dans le clergé africain
il a répondu que ça n'existait pas selon
sa théorie ça s'explique parce que
l'homosexualité ne fait pas partie des
traditions africaines alors la ciat
vraiment à le vider au vatican pas sûr
qu'il fasse campagne pour le cardinal
turkson même s'il faut reconnaître que
physiquement brasles sinon dans un autre
genre il y as shown bornes le cardinal
autrichien alors bien sûr après benoît
16 qui étaient aux jeunesses
hitlériennes un nouveau pas autrichien
ça serait du pain béni pour les comics
sauf que sean byrne est un vrai
progressiste il s'est prononcé en faveur
du mariage des prêtres et par ailleurs
au lieu de dénoncer l'invasion de
l'europe par les musulmans il a fondé
une revue intitulée aux épices qui
milite pour le dialogue avec l'islam sur
la photo un pape noir ça très moderne
c'est sûr n'empêche la dernière grande
modernisation de l'église date du
concile de vatican ii un concile qui a
été voulu par jean xxiii un vieux pape
italien de 77 ans voilà c'était
l'éditeur de l'aco mise en image de
julia la famille alberto toscano
bonsoir c'est cet écrivain et
journaliste
vous collaborez à de nombreux médias des
deux côtés des alpes et notamment au
quotidien italien oggi bienvenue d'un
million
alors le pape a démissionné faut dire
que bossait km que tu vois jamais c'est
pas très motivant non
ah bon
ice et détient comme patron on dit aussi
qu'il a démissionné parce que vous
l'appeliez toute la journée pour qui
luttent plus contre le mariage gai
voulu foutez la paix aux papes combat
non mais sérieusement là je parle c'est
annuellement parce que c'est un jean un
italien qui s'appelle la repubblica qui
a dit que c'était à cause du lobby gay
que le pape démissionner quand même bien
sans doute au vatican des centres de
pouvoirs opaque mais comme à la télé
non il ya des salles ne pouvait repas
que le plus connu est là où l'opacité
sans doute touché des niveaux
inquiétants pour tout le monde aussi
pour ceux qui me croient pas et le ior
la banque du vatican qui s'est prêtée à
des opérations financières plus que
douteux douteuses dans le passé
aujourd'hui il ya un point dans le
discours de benoît 16 qui est très
intérieur dernier qui est très
intéressant il dit il ya des nuages
inquiétants oui et ça peut même aussi
expliquer le fait qu'un homme à son âge
a choisi d' laisser la place à quelqu'un
qui programme aura plus les énergies
vous nettoyez les nuages pour le tour
marina votre père est italien vous
comprenez tout ce que dit elle des
retouches
facile vous ça vous intéresse le pape
dia pas trop
parce que ça m'intéresse si celle ci se
trouve que là c'est quelqu'un de
progressis qu'on ait eue et de plus
intéressant oui mais je m'en veux parce
que je suis pas catholique que je suis
pas croyante et de que je m'occupe pas
des choses qui me regarde pas voilà vous
intéresser aux barbes même s'ils devront
être pas avec eh oui je sais mais là je
sais pas c'est quelque chose qui m'a qui
m'est complètement complètement étranger
la religion voilà je préfère les
chapeaux qu'ils ont fait c'est ça c'est
ça c'est les chapeaux et puis tout ce
qui se dit tout ce qui est en dessous du
chapeau
oui j'avais vachement aimé le film donc
d'anticipation de nanni moretti habemus
papam habemus papam
non en fait je ne comprends pas c'est
quoi un lobby gay au vatican c'est quoi
l'action du lobby gay dont m vient
toujours de la bac du vatican qui dans
le passé aurait été mal r d opération
pas très catholique et
et pour faire taire ceux qui savent on
aurait utilisé des pressions aussi au
sujet de leurs attitudes sociales
jouer comme ça ils ont eu peur d'être
out et donc il y monte flip tout moment
alors les pronostics personnellement je
suis ravi que vous ayez parler du cas
les cardinals album parce que ce serait
un très grand pope un impact martha pape
qui est plus progressiste
voilà michel
quel est votre favori pour cette
élection je suis sur des positions de
gauche libertaire c'est à dire que quand
je parlais tout à l'heure du des
communistes il faut faire la part des
choses il ya l'appareil communiste qui
détestable et puis y'a plein de
militants communistes ils sont des gens
bien dans l'église c'est pareil c'est à
dire il ya un pape est cuit ya les
fidèles l'église les l'étymologie c'est
l'église a priori c'est pas le vatican
c'est l'assemblée des croyants et des
chrétiens donc moi j'ai moins souci des
papes 20 que de cette église et je suis
pas contre mais réponse tient ce qui me
gêne c'est que les chrétiens ne soient
pas où le soient si peu vous êtes ya un
lobby homosexuel moi ça me gêne pas ce
qui me gêne c'est que ces homosexuels
soient homophobes publiquement et rentre
dans une machine en nous disant les
homosexuels c'est des gens qui font la
fin de la civilisation c'est contre
nature ils sont anormaux comme les
pédophiles en bâtonnets c'est ce qui
s'est dit quand même une époque therrien
et discours homophobes de gens dont
certains sont homosexuels et se cachent
pour leur homosexuels je dis simplement
que il faut simplement être cohérent
mais quand on est chrétien et que on est
éventuellement un cardinal est
homosexuel et un truc qui va pas donc on
reste homosexuels mon art est d'être
cardinal j'avais failli être ambassadeur
de france auprès du vatican et pourquoi
vous avez refusé parce que je pouvais
plus faire de politique si j'étais à
ambassadeur
quelque chose
regrettait pas ça s'arrêtera ge le
premier choix de sarkozy c'était bigard
vous avez un favori un pape frein
seraient beaucoup mais je connaissais la
meilleure andré vingt-trois on l'a dit
est ce que vous voudriez pape il a dit
je parle que français se pâment des
français c'est qu'à part la garde et
strauss kahn n'y a aucun qui parle
anglais
et vous dites qu à la fois à la gare
bastos 15e des mauvais points oui
quoique strauss kahn aurait pu faire un
mort dia
alors il n'y a pas de chef au vatican il
n'y a pas de chef non plus en italie à
le pays hésitants troll le populisme de
berlusconi et de beppe grillo et la
combinazione de bersani est monté tout
ça donc on est vraiment dans une
situation viable l'italie a l'habitude
de croire au miracle et d'y croire
tellement fort que parfois il arrive à
les réaliser mais sans doute ce serait
très compliqué de sortir de cette
impasse et qui plus est effectivement
beppe grillo a réalisé une campagne
n'est pas le coluche et italiens il est
beaucoup pire qu'ils aient connu oui il
est arrivé à dire des phrases en france
il ya le pain anita laissez-moi exprimé
la même ford force de compteurs c'est du
populisme à l'état pur qui fait de
discours objectivement dangereux michel
une question quand même là on est dans
une situation incroyable c'est à dire
que quand c'est l'europe qui met menti
en italie qui voilà maintenant c'est lui
qui va vous dressez c'est un technocrate
il va faire des économies quand le
peuple vote ils votent pas du tout bon
mon type ce qui fait même pas 10%
qu'est-ce qu'on fait simplement quelque
chose qu'on n'entend jamais c'est à dire
que le nombre de gens qui sont contre
cette europe en france en italie et
partout ailleurs est considérable en
france contient un traité européen et
que la france les français votent contre
sarkozy et hollande as quand même voilà
dix bon allez hop on a une élite
politique européenne qui défend cette
europe qui nous envoie dans le mur et on
a un peuple qui en fait les frais et qui
dit on n'en veut plus on n'en veut pas
mais le
malheureusement il ya dans la crise
actuelle de tous nos pays il ya cette
vague de populisme parce que il est
facile de détruire il est facile de dire
des noms et au moment où l'italie a
besoin manifestement des solutions mais
le peuple n'est pas des clowns science
dresser de deux en espagne le 10 en
france on ne l'entend pas et quand le
peuple le dit on les allez vous faire
voir augmenter le peuple attendait
imaginé en duo pop oui c'est vrai vous
souffrez qu'est ce qu'on ferait déjà des
politiques de gauche digne de ce nom ce
serait ce serait un mélenchon qui
n'auraient pas le tropisme de cuba qui
n'auraient pas le tropisme de chavanges
le marxisme de lattes de robespierre que
pas défendre ça simplement moi je
souscris à tout ce que dit mélenchon
100% de sa politique intérieure me va
simplement le bipartisme français fait
que aujourd'hui on a le choix entre un
centriste de droite un centriste de
gauche les deux défendant la même la
même heure le même libéralisme et voit
très bien vous en pensez quoi la
situation italienne je pense que
elle est les prémices de ce qui va se
passer en france ouais et je pense que
l'europe est très mal partie là on a au
moins un point d'accord sur mélenchon
mais sur le fait qu'on n'écoute pas le
peuple qui souffre et qui ne veut plus
de cette europe nous ne pouvons pas nous
priver d'europe moi j'ai voté contre
maastricht jackpot et contre les traiter
mais il faut une construction européenne
mais pas sur la base de ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui izia c'est pour vous
qu'on se donne tout ce mal si vous avez
22 ans nous l'a dit et fait c'est pour
votre avenir qu'on discute comme ça
c'est pour vous je sais vous êtes mignon
merci
sommes toujours en compagnie de
christine boutin
royce vixiège
et nous accueillons notre habitude du
samedi 20 heures ce soir latifa ils
baignent athènes bonsoir
alors latifa liens non notre fils soldat
imad ibenge athènes tombés sous les
balles de mohamed merah et dans les
jours suivants le terroriste abate six
autres personnes dont trois enfants
quelques semaines après la mort de votre
fils vous décidez d'aller visiter le
quartier dans lequel mohamed merah a
grandi et là vous découvrez que le
terroriste est un héros de l'islam
depuis vous avez retrouvé un sens à
votre vie vous avez décidé de porter
secours à ces jeunes tenté par le diable
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à 20
heures
j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
talent ouais
super en extase aux joies allons-y
alors cette semaine ya tellement rien
que je vais commencer par la rubrique
cinéma façon je suis obligé à cesser
canal la cérémonie des césar c'est super
chouette tout ça
non mais il ya un côté très ludique un
filet des trucs qui pèse 10 kg de bronze
à des vieux qui doivent les trimballer
sans se prendre les pieds dans leurs
robes de soirée tous se montrent plus
que les vachettes et la voix off de
nathalie simon ont frisera le sommet du
glam agricole
près j'ai mes réserves esthétiquement à
césar c'est pas dire à un oscar qui a
subi un crash test
pour les césar c'est toujours pareil
hein c'est un film qui est nominé dans
toutes les catégories et qui au final
reçoit rien du tout alors cette année
c'était camille redouble très bon film à
seul défaut il ya une heure
quarante-cinq en trop
alors je n'ai pas vu ses côtes
totalement gratuit ce que julien c mais
à l'heure du tout payant un peu de
gratuité dans l'humour ne fait pas
nécessairement demain les césar qui se
pavanait parce qu'ils accueillaient
kevin costner ça c'est vrai c'est du
rêve du glamour je rappelle qu'à
l'époque de danse avec les loups edith
cresson était premier ministre
ça c'est la france c'est la france est à
hollywood ce que la province et à paris
on a l'impression d'avoir al pacino
alors que nous envoyer vos lignes
leclerc
engagement semaines difficiles la france
a perdu stéphane hessel non je pense que
tout le monde voit le père castor du
lieu commun engagé
stéphane hessel un mec tellement engagée
que lorsqu'il est né il portait déjà un
nom qui évoquait les poilus
indignez vous aviez vous qu'ils disaient
c'est vrai la paix c'est mieux que la
guerre le bien est supérieur au mal le
capitalisme c'est kaka ou petites
crottes flûte il est l'heure de changer
mes couches à le grand âge ce coma
éthylique sans alcool en tout cas c'est
un triste destin franchement révélé à 92
ans mort à 95 3 ans de célébrités
dans son malheur une chance trop âgé
pour faire ce plh
bon je dis ça à moi son bouquin son
fascicule j'ai adoré at-on jamais rendu
un si bel hommage à du helvetica police
enfin pour une fois que la littérature
s'engage aussi sincèrement contre la
presbytie pourquoi bouder notre plaisir
alors de façon c'était un résistant
assez à gages d'une attaque habilité en
france veut dire en france pouvoir dire
n'importe quoi c'est simple entre 40 et
45 soit a fait le mariole dans le maquis
soit à planquer des juifs dans sa cave
c'est
une fois que tu as fait ça même si tu te
mets à raconter que la terre est plate
tout le monde va trouver génial c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'est ce tu
veux christine c'est comme ça fait
penser à nina hagen jeune je dise ça
m'empêchait
bref politiques gauche rien à dire ils
sont impeccables certes le chômage bat
un nouveau record mais il faut être
honnête c'est un peu trop tôt pour
mesurer les effets du mariage gay sur
l'emploi
j'adore ce pays
droite on a eu des nouvelles de françois
fillon alors lui il a trouvé un nouveau
truc monté sur des tribunes convoquer
des réunions pour expliquer pourquoi il
sera candidat à rien françois fillon ou
l'homme qui est mène pas être là
alors il paraît qu'il va à la rencontre
des français il va labourer le pays
aller à la rencontre des vrais gens
c'est un peu le leitmotiv des comment
peut-on vouloir être proche des gens en
oubliant que la vraie souffrance c'est
de ne pas trouver de taxi à 2 heures du
matin samedi boulevard saint germain
glamour marine le pen
marine le pen aimerait qu'on reconnaisse
aussi le caractère parfois utile de la
colonisation à la balle a pas tout à
fait tort la colonisation c'est un peu
comme la torture en algérie on n'est pas
sûr que les bourreaux vont te laisser un
bon souvenir en revanche on est sûr
qu'ils vont te laisser un compteur edf
économie alors le patron de coca cola
est venu au secours de la france et des
ouvriers il a dit que les français
travaillent bien plus que trois heures
par semaine tu m'étonnes qu'il est ravi
avec la main d'oeuvre française rappelle
que son métier consiste à faire des
bulles d'un moment on
faut être honnête
impasse peillon veut réformer les
vacances d'été c'est quand même fou
supprimer la dernière raison valable qui
n'ont envie de faire prof
alléger les semaines alléger le
programme allégé les devoirs à la fin il
sortira plus des élèves mais de
l'aspartame que ce sera l'autre le goût
de l'intelligence avec 0% culture
générale de danser voilà l'avenir
romantisme dsk
alors une ex maîtresse de dsk qui pour
un énième bouquin sur lui alors ses
écrits par marcela iacub ce qu'on voit
la photo c'est diam's après une chimio
alors la fille c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est chercheuse au cnrs tout ça c'est
du passé rassurant quand il monte en
gamme quoi de la femme de ménage à la
philosophe c'est la preuve qu'il aurait
fait un bon président quand ils arrivent
à pénétrer toutes les couches sociales
[Applaudissements]
j'y pense faisant sept mois de relation
pour retranscrire des ébats sur le
papier comme quoi être chercheuse au
cnrs c'est pas forcément un gage de
rapidité d'esprit coalition et tout ça
au final pourquoi la nana elle est
tellement romancière du dimanche qu'au
bout de trois pages tapis j'ai qu'ils
agissaient de dsk
du coup forcément une amende de 60 mille
euros c'est vraiment le coup de maître
il va lui rester un sacré pactole à la
fin la meuf quotas nafissatou en sept
minutes elle touche le jackpot l'autre
aile mais sept mois à pondre un truc qui
lui fera toucher à peine de quoi
s'offrir un abonnement club med gym
coincé
avec
[Musique]
merci pour cette spontanéité
alors il ya sept mois alors évidemment
le l'avocat a négocié un truc génial
c'est qu'il faut faire figurer la
mention atteinte à la vie privée alors
ça figurer dans chaque exemplaire du
livre ça c'est vraiment la victoire de
dsk quoi le tipi se bat pour sa dignité
et son avocat obtient que dans chaque
bouquin on dise aux lecteurs et aux
ailes gros porc c'est bien mon client
voilà alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine
passée la fin de la chronique quoi pour
vous je sais pas mais pour moi y'a pas
photo
vous pouvez suivre l'activité mission et
réagir sur twitter via le compte les
terriens et le hashtag slt on passe
maintenant à notre invité du samedi 20
heures
[Musique]
latifa re bonsoir vous êtes né à tétouan
au maroc le 1er janvier 1960 votre père
était trompettiste dans l'armée
espagnole et votre mère femme au foyer
mais comme votre père est très coureurs
votre mère finit par obtenir le divorce
et elle quitte le maroc pour tienta qui
est une enclave espagnole sur la côte
méditerranéenne à côté de melilla voilà
avec d'ailleurs ses enfants c'est là
qu'elle rencontre son second mari qui
lui se comporte très bien et vous paye
l'école espagnole ça c'est une bonne
période pour vous latifa quelque chose
quand je pourrai pas oublié hélas vous
avez neuf ans lorsque votre mère meurt
vous vous retrouvez avec votre soeur
chez votre père à tanger hélas la
nouvelle épouse de votre père vous
traitent comme des domestiques et vous
interdit d'aller à l'école
mais c'est la souffrance de ne pas aller
à l'école ne pas apprendre c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que je quand je vois les
enfants oui et quand tu n'es pas les
urnes aux études que je dis moi j'ai pas
eu cette chance ouais
ce n'est qu'à 13 ans que vous serez
secouru par une tante vous dit mes mains
étaient violette des plaines de cloques
donc du travail vraiment comme comme une
esclave pour votre belle-mère mais nous
allons utiliser parce que comme on
n'avait pas de mère mon père est
toujours absent elle a profité de moi et
ma soeur de servir comme bonne
à 14 ans vous évader de cet univers vous
partez travailler en usine il ya une
période assez heureuse parce que vous
fréquentez un peu des gens des gens de
lusine les directeurs de l'usiné tout ça
ça c'est la nostalgie de ma jeunesse
j'ai découvert
une manière européen oui malheureusement
votre grand frère
fini par avoir les moyens de subvenir
vos besoins et il vous dit de rentrer à
la maison ils vous interdit de
travailler
ça c'était dur à 16 ans vous rencontrez
votre futur mari qui bosse à la sncf en
france et un an plus tard donc à 17 ans
vous le rejoignez en france à sotteville
les rouen ça nous faire un choc quand il
est arrivé non c'était trop dur dit
ouais c'est une ville qui parle pas
ouais je ne chante pas celle ci lance
alors là devant l'ennui qui vous
submerge vous décidé de nouer des
relations avec vos voisines et puis
surtout d'apprendre le français
vous vous dites c'est la seule façon de
trouver du travail si je veux me sortir
de là il faut que je parle bien le
français ça c'était le besoin
absolument fallait que j'apprends la
langue pour parler avec mes voisins avec
mes amis sortir de trouver ma liberté
c'était important mais cet apprentissage
du français vous permettra d'envoyer vos
enfants à l'école et alors ce qui est
fou c'est que quand vous faites de faire
les devoirs à vos enfants en fait vous
connaissez pas très bien donc je vous le
redis des fausses faute parce que vous
ne savez pas en fait et il fallait
montrer que je savais ouais il fallait
garder ce secret est que mes enfants il
avait une maman phase ii et j'ai trouvé
une faute sans faute voilà alors vous
voulez farouchement vous intégrer à la
société française vous dites à la maison
vivait comme des français vous fêtez les
fêtes catholiques ou se tait noël
et à l'extérieur vous voulez que vos
enfants fréquentent des français de
souche mais vraiment de sortir de votre
milieu je vais en france je me payais
j'ai fondé une famille et il fallait que
je vis normalement tout le monde de
culture de richesse et c'était important
vous les obliger pas à faire le ramadan
à vos enfants on ne doit pas obliger nos
enfants on doit laisser la liberté et
c'est là qu'un jeu votre fils imad celui
qui était le plus proche de vous ça veut
dire piliers mas
i mas nous annonce qu'il va s'engager
dans l'armée donc il devient
parachutiste il participera à un certain
nombre d'opérations l'opération épervier
au tchad et l'opération licorne en côte
d'ivoire
et un jour il vous dit tu sais maman il
se pourrait que je meure avant de toi
mais c'était difficile ça c'est ce jour
là c'est quelque chose que je ne pourrai
jamais oublier là aussi une assurance
elle m'a dit voilà s'il m'arrive quelque
chose moment surtout l'intérêt chez moi
moi j'ai des chiffres voici si le débat
chez vous si le pays d'origine et jeudi
c'est moi de mourir avant pas à fond de
toi et me dire lors quand on arrive on
n'a pas
et donc ils vous demandent de l'intérêt
annick à quelques kilomètres de tétouan
donc au maroc et puis le vendredi 9 mars
2012 vous êtes en voyage en turquie avec
votre mari c'est votre fille cimade qui
vous a offert le voyage
vous sentez nerveuse angoissé vous aimez
pas tellement l'hôtel où vous êtes vous
trouvez lugubre cet hôtel j'avais un
sentiment ce jour là c'est quelque chose
la standing mer j'avais un couteau dans
le coeur way et rim est cette heure-là
il était mort
sortie à konya des l'appareil vous avez
un sentiment d'oppression vous dites
comme si j'étais à l'intérieur d'une
tombe alors qu'à ce moment là vous ne
savez pas encore que votre fils est mort
vous rentrer à l'hôtel et c'est là que
votre autre fils à steam vous appelle et
vous annonce que votre fils a été tué
par mohamed mer
on ne sait pas encore à ce moment là
mais il tuera encore deux militaires à
montauban quatre civils à toulouse à
l'école juive ozar hatorah dont trois
enfants
alors ce qui est terrible c'est laquelle
des policiers toulousains quand vous
allez reconnaître le corps de votre fils
parce qu'il commence par lui dire mais
votre fils c'était un délinquant c'était
un trafic enfin comme si le fait d'être
arabe musulman était obligatoirement lié
à ça on était très humilié j'ai pas
encore vu mon fils elle est à la morgue
ouais j'étais pas encore sûr que c'était
lui et ses policiers il me parlait comme
sans coeur sans rien et c'est quelque
chose que je ne peux pas oublier et il
vous dit même un de vos garçons est il
capable de tuer son frère
je dis monsieur s'il vous plaît ouais
c'est trop dur qui vous venez de dire
laisse moi mon fils le lendemain elle à
la morgue et vous découvrez que votre
fils a été autopsié sans votre
autorisation
ça c'est un choc total parce que mon
fils il est mort il en salle et sa
mémoire
et d'aller à l'hôpital me dire madame
préparez vous ouais coups de fils et les
autopsies là c'est quelque chose
quand j'ai touché mon fils mais c'était
quelque chose de très vieux vous passer
plusieurs jours à la morgue
à leurs jours plusieurs tout
pratiquement tous les jours j'allais le
voir et ce policier quand je les demande
et je posais cette question pourquoi
vous avez fait cette autopsie sont
demandés il me dit madame gardez votre
calme
si vous continuez à parler comme ça je
vais raccrocher c'est là que j'ai
répondu jeudi me sucer c'est ma cercles
soldes c'est pas la vôtre
le 22 mars 2012 mohamed merah est abattu
par les hommes du raid vous vous auriez
préféré qu'il soit traduit en justice
aux kivus
s'expliquer et qu'on lui pose un certain
nombre de questions sur son geste bien
sûr c'était important pour nous - pour
toutes les familles
très important alors vous allez au maroc
enterrer votre fils donc la rime dit
qu'à côté de tétouan et là vous êtes
obligés d'appeler la chaîne qatarie al
jazira parce qu'il voulait diffuser les
images de la tuerie tourné par mohamed
mer
quelque chose horrible troisième jour de
jeu l'intérêt monfils est moi est
d'aller le matin sur sa tombe et je
ressens côté les formats sages appelée
au secours à tout le monde j'appelais le
qatar j'ai appelé la générale j'ai
appelé la france que le roi du manque ça
c'est quelque chose j'ai dit alors si
vous montrez ça vous verrez ma mort sur
la conscience et ça je te prête
et j'ai toujours peur jusqu'à maintenant
mais pourquoi il voulait diffuser cette
vidéo adhérents
c'est ça que je comprends pas et voyez
qu'un assassin qui a tué trois religions
oui les trois adultes le dessus des
enfants il a touché quand même la france
parce que c'est des soldats bien sûr
qu'il vit convient de montrer des choses
comme s'il très ambigu l'attitude du
qatar dans tout ça non
et là un jour vous êtes assise sur la
tombe de votre fils et vous avez une
espèce d'illumination vous décidé de
sauver ce qu'ils ont fait subir ce sort
à votre fils jeudi faut que je rencontre
un où il habitait mère à qui les
merengues et quand je suis à l'aise sur
ses jeunes si je les ai dit ce que mes
race est un héros oui ces martyrs des
excuses il a mis la france entière à
genoux donc sont fiers de lui
et quand j'ai parlé et que ces jeunes je
les cons je vais expliquer je me suis
présenté je vous assure et en changer
vous leur dites qui vous êtes
effectivement --moody's on vit comme des
rats et les rats quand ils sont enfermés
il devienne enragé
ceci étant permettez moi de vous dire et
de leur dire que si tous les gens qui
vivaient dans des cités tiré à bout
portant sur des militaires des enfants
juifs
donc vous leur dites mais vos parents
qu'est ce qu'ils disent quand vous dites
que mohamed merah est un héros etc et
ils disent nous nos parents de façon
leur en parle pas et si nos parents nous
voyez crever finalement ils seraient pas
mécontents j'ai répondu non c'est pas
possible
à chaque maire
hellemmes son enfant c'est parce que il
meurt quand et réagissent où ils
répondent comme ça son enfant parce
qu'elle n'est pas contente l'ebita ce
qu'il fait alors en mai 2012 vous lancez
une structure dead aux jeunes vous dites
je veux sauver ceux qui sont à l'origine
de mes souffrances c'est magnifique
quand j'étais au site et j'avais vu ces
jeunes sont perdus ouais sont livrés à
eux mêmes ils manquent de temps fiction
et manque d'être cadré il manque plein
de choses
cgs et on peut les récupérer il faut les
entendre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire la différence
il faut les aider tous les cadres et et
pour l'aider à faire des formations des
stages on doit pas fermer les yeux ce
que vous savez un jeune rien qu'ils
regardent ça parle non on doit pas
tourner le dos
si on le laisse comme ça ça va devenir
des bêtes sauvages oui on doit les aider
parce qu'ils ne sont pas quand ils sont
en france ce sont pas si sûr le français
quand il parle le pays d'origine et
savent pas s'ils sont way sont perdus il
faut des plus d'autorité de la part des
parents et certains parents qu'ils ont
oublié la leçon je pense saison oblige
éducation aux enfants moi je j'approche
beaucoup aux parents parce que les
parents sont responsables de leurs
enfants
[Applaudissements]
est-il ordinaire cet acte de pardon des
assassins de son fils ça c'est
extrêmement nous on dirait chrétien
c'est superbe c'est sublime bravo
[Applaudissements]
latifa de raconter cette histoire dans
un livre qui s'appelle mans pour la
france qui sort le 6 mars chez
flammarion merci de votre témoignage
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était salut les terriens à votre
source du samedi christine boutin
du parti chrétien démocrate
marina foïs
pour blé dur actuellement au cinéma un
trio calaisis izia higelin césar du
meilleur espoir féminin le dvd mauvaise
fille sort le 3 avril michel onfray les
freudiens l'éthique et les consciences
réfractaires c'est oublier chez grasset
alberto toscano du quotidien italien tu
es là tu pars i d'alyzia tel morts pour
la france
en librairie le 6 mars merci merci à
tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire cette
émission salut les gars
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu